le village coeur historique de la
commune de guyancourt avec l'église
saint victor la ferme fortifiée de
châteauneuf et des maisons anciennes
un espace urbain dorénavant protégé par
un périmètre d'étude un outil prévu par
le code de l'urbanisme pour contrôler la
construction de logements maintenant à
chaque fois qu'il ya une demande de
permis de construire sera déposé la
ville a trois ans pour surseoir sur
cette décision ce qui nous permet de
prendre le temps de bien protéger nos
villages objectif permettre d'étudier
les permis de construire pour préserver
le patrimoine et l'architecturé du
centre ville pourquoi là on est aussi
dans des maisons des bâtiments qu'on
veut protéger par exemple cette maison
là pour regarder qui est très haute
si vous voyez des vieilles cartes
postales de guyancourt c'était un hôtel
autrefois des cas d'espèce différents en
fonction de la volonté municipale et de
la zone concernée par le périmètre
d'étude avant d'en être arrivé là aussi
en nous disant je vais détruire cette
maison et construire une centaine de
logements c'est le terrain derrière et
est assez grand mais bon quelque chose
pareille totalement inacceptable pour
nous le fait qu'on ait voté ce périmètre
d'étude permet d'empêcher cela on a eu
de longues discussions avec le promoteur
avec des allers retours on leur fait
revoir leur projet
plusieurs fois on arrivait à quelque
chose d'acceptable on a fait baisser le
nombre de logements on a on s'est assuré
de l'intégration dans dans
l'environnement que c'est à des petits
immeubles qui on ressemble plus à des
grandes maisons enfin il ya tous ces
allers-retours avec le promoteur je
souhaite qu'on arrive à un accord est
finalement le projet se fait maintenant
alors je crois que ils ont vendu à peu
près tout cette prérogative municipal va
s'étendre sur une durée de 10 ans